14 passagers ont été blessés à cause de
fortes turbulences durant ce vol causant
des dégâts impressionnants dans l'avion
voici ce qu'il s'est passé alors ce vol
il a décollé de perte en Australie le 4
décembre pour atterrir à Dubaï le 5
décembre l'avion était un A380 de la
compagnie Emirates selon Fox News les
turbulan ont débutés lorsque l'appareil
s'est approché du Golfe Persique l'avion
aurait commencé à trembler violemment
selon les témoignages recueillis par des
médias australiens une passagère raconte
que le pilote a annoncé des turbulences
demandant aux gens de s'asseoir
littéralement une seconde plus tard
selon elle plusieurs pass passager
aurait été projeté vers le ciel frappant
le plafond ce passager raconte avoir
vécu son pire vol j'avais vraiment
l'impression que c'était la fin lorsque
nous avons heurté le plafond à deux
reprises je suis content d'être à la
maison cette passagère décrit elle un
vol horrible je déteste prendre l'avion
le pilote annonce des turbulences et
demande à s'assoir littéralement une
seconde plus tard moi-même et d'autres
avons heurté le plafond vous pouvez voir
mes cheveux dans la fissure au moins 14
passagers ont été blessés par ces
turbulence les secours les ont pris en
charge à l'aéroport de Dubaï